welcome to this video coverage of the
six round term of them look ma ho open
the tournament I played on my your
account yeah let's consider what did
happen until this round five games have
been played and I only lost one of those
five games against strong Ukrainian
Grand Master Sword ovni chenko but I one
or other four games so four out of five
really good result and yeah well at that
point it became interesting to calculate
what exactly would be necessary to score
a grandmaster norm um for those of you
not familiar with the mechanics them to
to get the Grand Master title you need
those so-called grandmaster norms you
need to perform in certain tournaments
above em yeah the given level I mean
this is the rating performance that you
need to be above that is 2600 for a
grandmaster norm so you basically have
to perform as you were 2600 player and a
given tournament which is quite
something I mean it is very often said
that what the GM toddler is not what it
used to be this is certainly yeah
there's certainly a grain of truth in
that but it's rather difficult to
perform a 2600 level at least for a
player like me who is 2400 and well I
have my good days and so on but 2600 is
tricky okay let's say um say what my
calculations i came to with four out of
five a header performance of about 2500
something and it looked like out of the
remaining four games i needed at least
three out of four against very strong
position so it was really necessary to
win I guess three games as you probably
will lose a game um or may maybe two
games to win the new draw two and a half
out of four if I would have get if it
would get very very strong opposition
like one of them two thousand six
hundred plus players in the tournament
um okay what I got in round six was a
grandmaster from Serbia dragon paunovic
she's rated 2480 so I'm for this purpose
a relatively low rated player I would
have preferred to have someone even
higher rated I mean winning is not easy
in any case and it just a better it just
increases your your rating average of
the opponent's ya 2 for 18 with the
white pieces and there was this
basically meant I better win this to get
a grandmaster norm I mean you need to
try at least okay what did I do I played
1c for a bit surprisingly maybe um but I
had my reasons i had done only a brief
preparation didn't invest so much time
in preparing as we explored the island
on that day and yeah i was checking his
repertoire and he usually played d 60 d
4 D 6 those kind of systems on Knight f3
d6 and later going to either Philidor
set up ya like like this for example on
he went like night a 3d 6d four and then
yeah returning to a king's indian setup
but in any case i would have a night on
a three the case in point is that i
don't want to do this because of a 5
which is considered very satisfactory
for black yeah I'm sorry for the long
talk about the initial moves but it is
very important here to to understand
what i did in the move on i played c4 I
recognized that he is a former Kings
Indian player and this d6 business is
only a recent addition to his repertoire
to avoid certain lines but then I saw
that on C form he usually goes g6 after
which this happened in the game i played
deform and now we will transpose back to
a king's indian type of position why i
actually don't have the night committed
so this is what happened and we're in a
regular Kings Indian so I pretty much a
tricked him a bit in the move order so
that he wasn't able to avoid the non
let's say yeah the lines with without 93
and in my preparation are also
recognized that against the arbor buck
this is this line he normally applied
employed a somewhat old-fashioned
variation and I was hoping to get
exactly that on the board and exactly
that happened he played c5 d5 and now a
6 this is what I meant with them
old-fashioned variation um this
connected with the e6 this is a very old
way to combat the Arabic which nowadays
is pretty much they are never played by
by strong players because it is
considered to be very passive the normal
recipe against this opening once you
have played c5 of course you have other
ideas um is to play h6 in this position
and only after the bishop moves let's
say it moves to be three only then play
six also after Bishop f4 which is
probably the more testing option even
after that black can play e6 offering
this d6
leads to very sharp play this is
possible variation red black with knight
c6 Queen out gets very good counter play
with good development this is how it is
played nowadays but he had played this
before and I was hoping to get it on the
board exactly that happened yeah quite
quite funny we I got exactly what I
wanted in the opening yeah he takes d5
that some one key point why does not
want to have this essa metrical benoni
type of position with the modern been
only type of position but play with eat
XD 5 this leads to a yam to to a
symmetrical pawn distribution
three-on-three on the Kings side four
against four on the queenside but white
always enjoys the space advantage d5
against e6 and yeah as we see black has
a problem and this problem is the light
squared Bishop how do you get it
developed the yeah their only real way
to to proceed here for blankets to play
Bishop g4 and exchange this Bishop it's
simply a piece that has no big purpose
so he went for that for this castles 97
and now I played age 32 to force the
trade takes takes and Queen B 6 yeah
this is the type of position that
normally arises from this a six and A
six move order or this line and this is
the reason why or this structure is the
reason why this line has fallen out of
fashion problem for black is he has very
very little counter play I played Quincy
to now which is the best move it gets
the Queen to see to where it covers very
important squares it covers eform it
covers b3 and the most important thing
is also it gives some room for the
bishop to
for the bishop to possibly retreat in
case of black goes for a queen bee for
counterplay yeah in case of Queen before
you probably want to play b3 after which
your night is loose and this you want to
overprotect with Bishop t2 also you will
need the bishop on the two to cover the
e1 square to fight for the e-file what
why does aiming at him is an endgame
actually and we will see that I get it
in the game and I will describe them the
finer points when we get to it he played
rookie five now taking this which I
didn't mind I just retreated to d2 and
now rupee eight so black has gotten a
very quick um doubling of rooks on the
e-file it looks nice at first but in
reality it's not really a big
accomplishment as after Luke fv1 this is
what what I played um those looks will
get traded anyway yeah and TM Chang yeah
it did this now himself I mean it was a
happening in any case so had this and
now Bishop h6 activating this Bishop
yeah and now a very funny effect and
what we have we reached this position
relatively quickly I mean he spent some
time and I basically played this here
almost almost instantly all those moves
and I had this on the board I'm not
quite sure how often in to two or three
tournament games and then some some some
blitz of rapid stuff so I knew what I
was doing a plane quickly and he played
this also quite quickly but he took some
time the fun thing is when I looked at
this afterwards I found a game between
white player Grandmaster constant in
lerner la la from
from the Ukraine and mr Palmer which
playing black in Belgrade 1988 so my
opponent 26 years ago had played this in
a tournament game and exactly the same
position was reached and here in the
game in Belgrade learner played Bishop
to d1 I played at Bishop e2 it's it's
very comparable those moves what why
does trying to achieve with Bishop e2 or
Bishop d one wants to make the F pine F
porn mobile go to play g3 at f/4 and
yeah to be honest I I need to tell you I
find it pretty remarkable that my
grandmas opponent is reached reaching
this position for the second time as it
is a totally unattractive position to
play I mean I personally find it totally
appealing to play this way as black as
you will suffer for for a long time you
have zero winning chances and yeah it's
just yeah it's on the brink of masochism
if you ask me to play like that yeah
wife why am I saying that the thing is
white has all the pluses that that he
wants he has got two bishops very nice
those bishops are not very well placed
at the moment but they can be improved
Black has absolutely no targets to
attack for example this Bishop is
pointing into thin air it can never
attack anything especially considering
that I will play a role play b3 at some
point those light squared pawns can
never be attacked by the bishop white
will also gain space and this is why I
played Bishop e2 I want to play g3 f4
possibly g4 and gain space on the King
side especially f4 is useful in the long
run as it control it is a very important
to e5 square blacks nights are
completely without any purpose and the
only thing that black can do here is
and try to hold on and it's not a very
very positive positive way to play in
fact in this game against learner in two
thousand in 1988 my opponent also lost
so it's a bit of a mystery why you went
for this a second time yeah played
Bishop f4 trying to activate this Bishop
via e5 I played b3 first this belongs
into the general concept anyway so I
went for this and Queen back yeah the
queen is not really doing anything on b6
it looks like it at xp3 but the reality
is white will expand on the Kings side
and you better have the Queen available
as a defender yeah g3 should be five and
first now kingi to ya f 4 immediately
also was possible but King g2 belongs
into the position anyway I want to play
f/4g for and ideally even g5 if you have
met if you imagine this in your in your
head once i get to g5 this night will
move and then the bishop will be active
on g4 yeah this is the idea white wants
to expand the pawns on the kingside this
way also activating the bishops and very
often there are long-term problems that
black has to face for example if you
imagine I had to get the pawn to g5 the
Bishop to g4 at the end there might be
Bishop c8 and I'm getting the pawns it
looks like a very long-term plan but I
can assure you I have won games like
this exactly like this I have won the
Queen cited in a number of games it it
simply does happen in the long run and
black has very little active play yeah
he has started here with ruki a a 98 for
Bishop p.m. and Bishop platoon yeah I
need to get the the bishop away from you
one it's just not well placed there so
Bishop t2s serve is it
move and he played f5 yeah it's very
tough for black 22 to play this without
f5 in the long run in fact instead of
Bishop d2 you could have thought about
playing G form I wasn't sure about this
because of the screens the text f4 and
it's a bit yeah how do I actually
protect this I need to play something
like this which I didn't like maybe
still it would have been interesting to
play G 4 I thought I can do it anyway
but well f5 is not it's not something
that I am afraid of I want to play g4 of
course but I want to have it prepared
yeah I played Bishop f3 first Queen e7
and 92 yeah the knight on c3 I wasn't
doing much what it wants to do it do is
it wants to go to g3 yeah like G 493 and
then two pieces will put pressure on the
f5 Don ideally I want to play G for him
let him take and then push g5g for takes
takes and g5 so that Bishop g4 is
possible and the e4 square then is
cleared it's all about this G for
advanced that now is being prepared it
went back with the bishop probably
didn't want me to take them and here we
get to to a very critical situation um
of course look at the position what is
the most obvious move that white has in
the position and I saw it of course g4
the thing is what I calculated was g4
here black absolutely must take on g4 he
cannot afford something like night g7 in
this position let's say g5 the bishop
moves somewhere in fact here does not
even have a good square available but in
general this structure
now the problem is some that him he will
probably will need to allow me to take
it but what I'm getting at is this
general structure with pawns on this
this year is very problematic as wide
long term has the plan to play h4 h5 and
even h6 and once the light moves from g
7i have peace sacrifices on f5 you know
I'm going to put this on the bar just to
show the general idea I play I'll play
nothing moves here for black yeah and in
this position it is just a matter of
time let's just do this until I
sacrifice on f5 and this will be
absolutely deadly just okay here there's
a check on e2 we are just ignore the
check on you too this is what I'm
getting at h7 is lost and those pawns
are totally strong it just about the
structure black here would have Queenie
too okay yeah it's just to show the the
general strategic idea what widest is
aiming for this is why after g4 he must
take and of course I saw that he will
take take but what I was worried about
at first I just wanted to play this
instantly right like your hand wants to
play the move and probably I should have
should have in a way listen to to my
hand because it was a strong yeah then I
got worried because there is g5 of
course not a happy move for black as it
weakens f5 and and h5 but on the other
hand it probably will gain the e5 square
for peace as this pawn on f4 will at
some point move or yeah we'll get
captured the thing is as so I didn't see
a very a very important point on the
resource I saw this move of course
intending Knight to f5
but after night g7 in my calculation I
couldn't really find a great
continuation in the sir in this specific
position however vite has a very strong
wolf but this I absolutely did not see
um I only looked at stuff like this say
let's say taking yeah this is not
convincing he will get a very nice
square on e5 why it still retains a bit
of something but I didn't want to give
him this e5 square um yeah this is what
I so I also calculated 94 it also is a
nice position but yeah well I didn't
want to give him that in fact it turns
out White has a very strong move and
this is pointed out by the computer
Queenie for that's the absolute
strongest move into position the thing
is that black now yeah cannot take
himself 94 is essentially a double
attack on GF d6 and g5 this will win
immediately and yellow black cannot take
but what is the movie should play if he
takes I get to take only seven and now I
have misplaced his bishop on his heaven
it is not able to go oops not on that to
go on the long diagonal so after Bishop
here after the recapture black is forced
to play Knight e5 absolutely the only
move otherwise 94 for basically windy 60
95 and after that I have a very very
nice choice I can just return to eat too
maybe the best smooth I can try to make
this work without which also keeps a
very distinct advantage probably bit
should be two is the best move after
which again Bishop f6 is completely
useless as 94 strong or g5 they're both
strong this would have led to a
fantastic endgame position really
Queenie force just
just a strong move it helps to get the
bishop SF and I didn't see the move and
this is why I didn't play g4 and
probably this was this was the moment in
the game where I let and at some of my
advantage slip the thing is at the end I
decided to play Queen to d3 and tendon
Queen III yeah gaining the e-file or
exchanging Queens that's not a bad thing
in general I don't mind that queens are
traded the the big point is now after
Queen d3 he got in 97 and now g4s not
making more sense I mean I should have
played it the move before this was the
idea and now after the trade he got in
age 5 and this is far less convincing in
terms of g4 because black gets to trade
another pawn he can take with the h-bomb
yeah the position here is still better
for white of course but with g4 it was
much more forcing and was simply
increasing my advantage one here I'm
better but I'm not yeah I'm not having a
close to the size of edge after g4 I
probably would have would have won the
game I mean not sure but it looks very
very strong the next thing that I wasn't
sure about in this position is should I
play against him positioning the pawns
on b6 and 85 yeah the b6 a five set up
is something that black can do to try to
completely shut down the position yeah
the pawns on light squares here or be 7
a-6 no term can be a problem with the
bishop coming to c 8 I know it looks
fantastic at the moment but there is g4
and an opening of the of the kingside
coming so Bishop to c8 can be a point
and I wasn't sure if I should do
something against this maybe I should
have done something
against it I play G form here after
which she took king of 893 and now we
went a 5 i'm still on one hundred
percent sure but i think given the
things that happened afterwards I
probably should have played Bishop b2
here just making sure that he cannot do
this b6 is always a bit tricky due to a
five yeah not what like once I'm like b6
intending a failure so maybe I should
have played Bishop b2 to give me more
chances in the same game the way it went
down he played a five we should be to be
six and Bishop e2 yeah it's of course
still very one-sided like we're never
ever going to threaten anything in the
game yeah it's totally passive but how
exactly do you break through he's just
yeah trying to to keep this position as
is and yeah I don't really know how to
break through him he am positioned his
King on f6 now and covered f5 and his
rationale is too after taking on a five
just recapture and yeah set up something
which is very much a fortress yeah it's
a very passive but what else is there I
have analyzed it a bit um and I really
couldn't find a way to break through him
I mean maybe there is a way but i didn't
i didn't find one in the game and
afterwards also i couldn't i couldn't
couldn't make it work I mean it is
passive and everything but I I don't
know how to break through one thing for
example that a Triton analysis is this
king age for this should have two am
trying to to pin him
and yeah let's say bishops III check we
should deform just a sample line trying
something else this is the key idea
attacking d6 even this while being yeah
very passive I don't really see how to
win this I mean blackest is probably
holding might be five yeah looks
attractive at first but he's got 94 96
not be three and i'm still not sure I'm
going to win this maybe this is the
better chance compared to the game I
mean why term if anyone is better is
white but it's still tough to see how to
win it yeah i played this move because i
thought yeah combining this with the the
pressure here would be a good idea I
went I went to e3 I wanted to go to e
398 Bishop here but he went Bishop see
one to two to keep it to keep the
position yeah I gave the check here yeah
maybe I should have tried bishop h4
check yeah yeah maybe but i really i
really didn't see how this would improve
my chances yeah yeah for example let's
say i take here and he recaptures yeah
and then here he's got laid h5 check
yeah now we only have pawns on on one
side of the board they don't think this
should be enough to to win it I mean
it's it's totally unattractive to play
like this with black but maybe you hold
the draw I mean it's a it's not fun but
maybe still a draw yeah maybe just this
just just staying how exactly am I going
to win him yeah I went here and say I
hope that I can do something in this
structure my idea was to get the night
over to age for trying to win the pawn
but it didn't work Nigeria yeah he can
just cover it with the king the ante
udders of course he only has this Bishop
a3 move there is nothing else but it is
enough night g1 and now important this
temple on the bishop I don't want to
exchange went back and again he's
attacking him so Knight f3 is not
working he can just just take him yeah
this is what I tried to check but he can
always attack air for check
yeah 93 9 p-5 looks good but he's got
this month went here yeah again I was
trying this we repeated a couple of
times yeah I had the idea to to try to
reach b5 like that huh not sure that it
would have won or anything but it was
the last idea but look no I was
repeating once he's just in time to be
able to exchange this night yeah yeah
the whole black game is a sort of a
goalkeeping effort just trying to pick
to play without the other side scoring a
goal yeah he went night before trying to
force matters i mean and i basically
need to take now and otherwise he might
even get something himself so i took
here and here i actually offered the
draw he had he had offered the draw
before which I of course the client I'm
not quite sure at which point but I was
always being being better in some way at
least I had them I was the only one to
being able to try anything yeah here it
is just totally totally blocked there's
no no way whatsoever to to make any
headway you can you can give from a
check here but black can just take it
end and and stay with the King here it's
really totally dead yeah I think the key
point was when I played when I played
Queen d3m probably should have trusted
my first instinct that g4 must be the
right move and it was the right move um
it is always tricky because the thing is
you see that well g4 looks promising but
ok you see the capture you see g5
yeah this this type and you think okay
maybe it is a Miss time move where black
actually is gaining something like the
e5 square but it's it's it's a very very
tough decision to make is it a case of
your strike while the iron is hot where
you need to do something otherwise the
this window of opportunity is is passing
or is it a case of don't hurry yeah this
is a very important thing in technical
positions endgame positions where you
don't want to get sell off too cheaply
and I wasn't sure the main point was i
saw night g3s on ig7 but here i always
thought that after this trade his bishop
would get active and I didn't see
Queenie for which really makes sure that
his Bishop stays on e seven if I would
have seen Queenie for I would have
played this but as simply I didn't even
consider the move I guess and yeah these
are probably the points well where you
need to be alert and find the right
moves to score such a such a grandma
sent on 2600 rating so yeah a bit of a
disappointment I mean it was totally
one-sided game where I never ever got
into any any danger of losing but of
course if you are sort of yeah dictate
matters little game you pretty much want
to win which which simply didn't
materialize at the end yeah I hope you
enjoyed the game anyway it's a very it's
a bit of a slower slower slow moving
moving battle but still interesting to
to see this g4 point was the most
interesting in the game all right I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching